This is something
that technology cannot solve on its own.
You have to had much more empathy
and compassion and insight
into the human psychology.
Really understanding
the emotional barriers
that go into people like,
having difficulty
to change their behavior.
And what are the mechanics
that you can build into that.
Michal Levin, thank you
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm great, how are you?
Happy holidays.
Happy holidays to you, too.
I'm so excited to talk about
user experience with you.
Like I mentioned,
I didn't get to talk to it
about nearly enough
in the 300 episodes we've had.
And I'm super excited to dig deep
into the importance of user experience
and in everything we do,
both in tech and startups,
but in daily life as well.
And before we get started,
I have to say
your experience with UX is remarkable.
I think that I saw
about a dozen different organizations
that you've made an impact
on in the world of UX
all the way from a startup like Zoox
to a Google, to Verily, and now Hero.
So, tell me a little bit about
your journey.
How do you even get started
with dealing with user experience?
Yeah. That's a great question.
Those are quite a few years back.
Actually, the story starts back in Israel
where I was born and raised.
And after I finished my army service,
I actually join a company.
And that's kind of like
was my entry to the tech industry.
And I actually, join as a QA.
And I started working there.
And back in the days it was about,
what, probably,
about 15 to 20 years ago,
UX in Israel wasn't an industry.
Like there was no education around
and there were not
a lot of companies that was doing that.
It was just like early on
where mostly engineers were just like
building the UI's based on what they
thought was the right thing to do.
And I actually remember those early days
where I was doing QA
and I was testing
the functionality of the product.
But I kind of started also asking,
just like intuitively all this question
as to why, you know,
why do we have all these menu items,
like why does the workflow
work like this.
And I started just like
within the culture of that company.
We started talking about this idea
of usability and UI super early on.
So, that's kind of like
was the early, early seeds.
Then I actually went to a school
and I started Computer Science
and Business Management.
However, halfway through my degree
actually decided that computer science
is not what I want to continue doing.
I didn't see myself just like,
you know, exiting and coding.
I really wanted to see
how I can bring more people
to focus creative doing
into kind of like what I do in my career.
So, I paused.
I started exploring,
kind of like what I want to do next.
And I ended up actually
going on to multiple route of psychology
and communication as one bachelor degree.
And I also continued
my business management
as a parallel path.
And I continued
with these two bachelor degrees.
And I really enjoyed it.
But then kind of like as I was studying,
I was like, okay,
what am I going to do
with all these degrees,
like, what does that translate to.
And while I was in school,
I kind of like went back to this like,
oh, you know, there was this UX thing
that I kind of like started back then
and I think super interesting.
And it made me feel like
this could be something that I'm good at
that really brings together
this like the cognitive psychology
with technology.
So honestly, what I ended up doing
is one evening,
I just opened Google
and I just search for all
the UX companies in Israel
and I just applied to all of them.
I wrote a cover letter explaining
why I think bring I value to that company.
And I just like throw it out there.
A couple of companies got back to me.
I got an interview process
and luckily enough, I landed in TZUR,
which was kind of like
one of the top design agencies in Israel.
And that was actually my entry point.
So, you go into an agency,
it's just like all about,
like having a lot of UX people there.
I worked there for almost four years
and I think I built a lot of
just like hands on experience
and understanding,
working with dozens and dozens of clients
across so many different platforms,
you know, mobile and web
and TV and across
like media and finance and gaming.
And that gave me, like,
so much experience with that.
So, yeah.
So, that kind of like how I started.
From there,
I actually joined Modu,
which was founded by Dov Moran,
one of the top entrepreneurs in Israel.
And during my work at Modu,
actually nine months into my work there,
I was approached by Google.
And a funny story was that I had a doubt
like I don't want to pursue that.
Like I was very happy at Modu.
And then a friend of mine said like,
"What are you saying?
Are you crazy?
You know, get started,
go through the hiring process.
You can always say no at the end."
So, I started.
And it ended up
being a really long process.
It was about
seven months of hiring process
because it was
the first UX hire in UX Israel.
So, I had like, 14 interviews
across, like around the world,
on [--].
Yeah.
But during that time,
seven months of interviewing,
you start getting excited
about the opportunity.
And it feels kind of like this
psychological connection
and I ended up getting hired.
And this is how
I started my Google journey,
which really kind of like a company
in over the following decade.
I spent six and a half years with Google.
I moved to the US,
through Google.
I worked at Verily,
and now I'm at Hero.
Unbelievable.
I have to give the analogy.
I never wanted to be a pilot.
My father was a pilot.
And when it came down to going
to do the army testing
which we do in Israel,
of course, you know, I said, okay.
You know, they're inviting me to try.
I knew that I didn't want to be a pilot.
And but all my friends said,
"Well, Michael, you have to try.
Like, you know, it's like,
you have to see if you can make it."
And I remember they sent me
to the [--]. It was one
of the worst weeks of my life.
And I'm traumatized by it until today
because it was so difficult.
By the end of it when I was accepted,
it was so hard to say no.
Even though I didn't want to be a pilot,
I felt like I just had to do it
because I got through it.
As if it does mean to myself.
But I have to give that analogy,
And I think you set it on.
You said that they hired you
now, you said yes.
That's what I think it's,
it more comes down to,
from what I'm gathering from the story.
Michal, break it down for me.
User experience.
You mentioned the psychology,
communication, computer science,
disintegration of
understanding user behavior.
Break it down for me.
What is user experience
and why is it so fascinating to you?
Yeah. That's a good question.
I think, at the end of the day, you know,
it's kind of like it's starting
with understanding
why are we doing these things, you know.
You start with the why.
I think that's going to, like
one title commonly associated
with Simon Sinek,
I think I kind of like very much
relate to that.
It's really like starting to think about
what you're doing
and what you're building
by truly understanding what people need,
what are their pain points,
what are their mental models,
behavior weaknesses,
where the psychology really kind of like
going deep into understanding
what is the problem
that you're trying to solve,
what are the common barriers,
what are the pain points.
And really starting from
their needs and goals,
doing that analysis
really understanding the people
and the audiences that you are trying to
to solve the problem for,
and go from there.
So, it's not about starting
with the technology
and everything we can do because
the technology can do X and can do Y,
which is what we call
a tech driven approach.
It's a user centered approach.
Like, let's understand,
what do people even need
and then see what is the best way
to do that.
And again, it doesn't mean
that we necessarily need to do
all the fancy stuff.
We really need to hone in
on what are the key needs.
I think a good example for that
and for that kind of like
how it manifests itself,
i actually think the last couple of years
working in healthcare
is a really great example.
Michal, new background,
new environment, same user experience,
same question.
Talking about health care a little bit
from your experience as well.
Why is your expertise
with health care an interesting example
of the importance of user experience?
Yeah, I think it's a really great example
of the difference between
technology focused approach
and user centered approach.
Because, you know,
there's a lot of promising technologies
and things that we can do.
Machine learning and AI,
and we can build all these amazing tools
and do sophisticated things.
But when you actually try to innovate
within healthcare,
what you realize that oftentimes
when you try to build tools
for like health systems physicians,
the secret and what would actually
get you to change
and move the needle
is how well you can integrate
into their existing workflows.
So, if you stop building
all these amazing tools,
but they're actually a separate tool
that they need to log into that,
they need to open it,
they need to learn.
that is a huge barrier for adaption.
And oftentimes innovation would come
by like finding the ways
that you can integrate into their EHR.
And even if the EHR UX is not great,
this is where they're at.
And you need to find the creative ways
of integrating yourself there,
and being in it as part of the workflows
and seeing how through there
you can bring value to them.
So, oftentimes it's not necessarily,
like all the amazing,
beautiful technology
that we can build independently
is really finding their way
to tapping your cells
into their busy schedule
and really understanding
that they have like,
five minutes a day
to take a look at these things.
And if you want to squeeze yourself
within their daily routine,
it's not going to be
with building a whole other tool
outside of their kind of like habits.
I think that's a fascinating example.
Because, you know,
it's the entrepreneurial mindset of any,
especially young entrepreneur is saying,
Okay, we have this idea and
we want to make it all around
beautiful products
that are all login screen
and are all user experience.
And we're so excited to show this
on encompassing product when
if we forget a little bit about
the customer that at the that
needs to use the product
and what their behavior is
and how are we fitting
into their behavior,
then we might have
this crazy misalignments
where nobody
can even use your product
because you're not aligning
to what they actually need.
Why isn't the engineer in the room
or the project manager in the room
enough to understand this?
Why is there
a specific role called user experience
Why is there this function
within a company?
Why isn't it enough that engineers
just think critically
about their customers
and just adapt to that?
Yeah. It's a great question,.
And I would start by saying that again,
like the culture that
I've been raised on
and I truly believe in.
It's not like that the UX person
is the only one
that solves all the problems.
I think it's like continuously
collaborative process
where we work together,
engineering and product
and UX bringing
all the considerations together,
thinking through user problems.
I think it's important
across the organization,
whether you're a product manager,
engineer, regulatory person,
to have a shared understanding
of what are we building,
why we're building,
who are our user.
So, I think this is actually something
that culturally we need to be shared.
I think in terms of like
when do we need it
like, why do we need a dedicated role?
I think it's just that
a full time job to do that work well.
And at the end of the day,
it's just like any role.
Like, why do we need PGMs?
Like, can't a PM be a PGM?
In some scenarios, yes.
Like, people can build that skillset.
I think it's just like
at the end of the day,
like, you have a limited bandwidth,
there's work to be done.
And if you want to do it well,
you need dedicated resources
that can have the bandwidth to do it.
So, if a PM needs to,
like a PM can also code.
Why not them the engineers?
Well, because if they need to have to code,
they going to need to spend
half the day on it
so, they don't have the time
to collect the business requirements
and do like landscape analysis
and talk to customers.
So, I don't think it's necessarily
like people that have
like a specific super power
that others cannot learn or gain.
It's more about how do you build
a healthy organization
where you put your resources
on the key things that have to be,
you know, super thoughtful,
go deep and truly understand,
so, we do build the best product.
I think that's fascinating.
And one of the things that
I'm always asking myself\
in the context of user experience is
the way that I think
about user experience
to some degree is thinking, okay,
we have this intuition about
how we should approach
solving the problem for our users.
And user experience professionals
can help us navigate that intuition
into practicality and research data
driven analysis of what actually
do our users needed,
how do actually can we
use our intuition to navigate there.
And one of the things
that I'm always asking myself is
how do you even know
that there's a problem.
Right?
How do you know that
if I have a hundred functions
within a company
and I'm guessing
within Google and Verily,
in those different companies
you've been a part of,
there were many, many aspects
where user experience was important.
How can the CEO,
the engineer or the product manager,
even pinpoint the parts where
a user experience professional
may be of use?
Yeah. Well,
i think kind of like as you said,
it starts with like research
and really understanding
what we're trying to solve.
So, I think every entrepreneur,
every CEO, every product manager,
they usually start their initiative
by observing a problem.
By observing an unsolved need
or a need that is not
being solved well enough.
And then in order for you
to tackle differently,
so, you sometimes
if you went to this personally,
you already have some insights around
what you experience is being
like the key barriers or the key gaps.
If you're trying now to say, okay,
how do we build
a scaled product out of that,
you need to do kind of go deeper to say,
how much is your experience
actually applicable more broadly.
You want to understand
what are the target audience
that apply to that.
And there's a lot of research
that needs to go
into understanding more deeply
what does that intake.
So, again, like,
where are the problem's coming from,
what are people's expectations.
As well as, you know,
in an ongoing way,
as you develop the product,
whether it's based on your intuitions
and kind of like your ideas,
you want to validate that.
And again, you need people that
can go and thoughtfully do that.
So, you know,
there's like different approaches.
Often times people just think
that they can go to people and say,
Would you like this feature?
Would you find this feature useful?
Which, again, kind of like
for a lot of people,
it feels like intuitive to do.
But that actually doesn't generate
and like any viable results.
Because whenever you ask anybody
if they want this or that,
they will usually say yes.
Because why not
if they can get more.
But there's a lot more that goes into it
because what you end up seeing
that people use maybe 10% of the features
that you offer them,
because at the end of the day,
would they actually use the product.
Then there's trade offs
whether in terms of complexity and time
and all those things,
they're not going to use it.
So, you do need to have
particular skills to do the research well.
So, you gain the right insight
that you can rely on.
Also, you really want to have,
kind of like, holistic approach
to look at qualitative data
and quantitative data.
And again,
doing all of that, it takes time,
requires expertise.
Also, how do you design things well.
Like how the whole
there's a whole, like, investment now.
And this is an area that I'm also like,
super excited about is like
this whole idea of behavior change.
And I think that's another angle
that to me represents how important UX is.
Because we see it again in healthcare
but everywhere.
You can build all the most
amazing devices,
whether it's wearables
or like all of the crazy stuff
that we see that is amazing.
But between having an amazing device
and getting people to use it every day,
there is a big, big gap.
Right?
This is why we see that like obesity
is like more prevalent than ever.
And like changing behavior
of the people is so so hard.
I think this is where,
this is something
that technology cannot solve on its own.
Like, you have to have much more empathy
and compassion and insight
into the human psychology,
really understanding
the emotional barriers
that go into people kind of like
having difficulty to change
their behavior
and what are the mechanics
that you can build into that.
So to me, that's another area
where I see healthcare
like UX is critical.
To really change
people behavior and scale,
it's still an unresolved problem.
UX is critical.
And I think this is what I see
a lot of the value that comes
by really going deep on these areas.
It's fascinating beyond belief.
I just read a really interesting article
by one of my former bosses,
Kristen Berman from the Irrational Lab.
One of Dan Ariely's projects.
And he was talking about the vaccine.
Like thinking about the covid-19 vaccine
and the user experience behind
that whole distribution.
And now, we were in this situation
where we need
like 75% of the world
to take this shot voluntarily
in order to resolve this pandemic.
And it's fascinating, I think.
Thinking of behavioral economics and help.
And you see prime ministers
going on live television
doing it themselves.
Like that's a part
of the user experience journey.
Right?
And I'm really wondering, sometimes,
how much thought really is put
into these critical, critical things.
I have a hunch that it's not enough.
And we need more people like you to help
advise these [--].
But that's fascinating.
Michal, we don't have much time.
But give me a few key insight nuggets
for the young entrepreneur
of how to approach
solving user experience issues
or intuitions as they build a company,
whether it's for B2B or B2C,
doesn't really matter.
Yeah. That could be a topic
for an entire conversation.
I think I would go back to kind of like
where I started.
It starts with why.
And I think this is also,
when I interview UX people,
when I look for UX people,
I start with looking
at their critical thinking
and their problem solving skills
before the visual aesthetic
and the ability to design a screen well.
You really want
to have people that keep asking why.
Really understanding like,
why are we doing that,
why are we doing it this way,
can we simplify it.
Like really keep asking this why.
And it's pretty interesting.
I have two toddlers
and I think those behaviors,
they ask why like 10 times on everything.
They go, but why, but why, but why.
And you know, as a parent
it would sometimes be challenging.
But I think that's the right mindset.
And I think over time along the way,
we start asking those deep whys.
But I think that those whys
and going like three whys in,
you know, the first principle approach.
Really understanding
why we need a certain things
and how can we do it better.
I think this is where innovation
starts from.
So, that would be kind of like
my top advice in terms of the mindset.
Because I think
it starts with the mindset.
And the more you ask those why,
I think this is where you start thinking
about things differently.
The other thing I would say
is what I think like personal experience
is many times provides good intuition
as to where we need to go.
We do need to remind ourselves
that you are not the user in most cases.
So, we need to be humble,
we need to make sure
that we're not making
too strong assumptions based on
our own experience
and take the time to truly try
and understand the audience
that we are targeting
and where they are coming from
and what are their challenges
and making sure that we have the empathy
and we really incorporate that into
how we approach the product
and we validate and we learn.
Because those things are changing
all the time.
So, yeah.
I think that's just inspiring.
So, thank you, Michal, for that.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
My favorite question.
Okay. So, three words.
I'm probably going to,
I'm going to cheat a little bit
because I'm going to use
the two words for each one.
But there is a hyphen there
so, theoretically speaking, it's one.
I think one thing about myself that
characterizes me, I think,
in everything that I do
and also my career is
just like people-focused.
I think it all starts with the people.
Hiring the right people,
building the right relationships,
being really people focusing,
kind of like what people need,
how you can grow them,
how do we work with them as peers.
That's going to be one.
The second is growth-minded.
I think constantly,
like I seek feedback, I seek growth.
I want to grow as an individual.
I want to grow as a professional.
I am a big believer
in the approach of atomic habits.
Get 1% better every day.
And so I really do seek
those avenues of growth constantly.
And the last thing I would say
is daring-greatly.
Which is a concept
that has kind of become more popular
with Brené Brown books,
which I absolutely admire.
I think she is she's brilliant
and she like the type of messages
that she's trying
to kind of like disseminate
are so important on vulnerability
and imperfection.
But to me, that's kind of like
this idea of like being in the arena,
fighting, putting in the blood and sweat
and failing and overcoming obstacles
until kind of like you ideally succeed,
but really kind of like not just critique
and point from the side
of what's not working.
But really being there and trying
and working hard for worthy outcomes
and do your best.
I just love that.
Michal, thank you so, so much.
This was wonderful.
I appreciate your time so much.
I know how busy you are.
And all I can say
is stay safe and stay healthy.
And thank you for the amazing
work that you're doing.
Thank you.